bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france des mesures dures si donc par le
président la nouveauté désormais les
bars et les restaurants qui vont devoir
vérifier la situation sanitaire de
chaque client dès le mois d'août
comment vous accueillez cette nouvelle
mesure alors encore un coup dur bonjour
à vous d'abord quoi bon encore un coup
dur pour nous pour la restauration
bien sûr je me demande des fois mais
qu'avons nous fait au bon dieu mais nous
n'avions pas le choix nous avons été
reçus la semaine dernière par les
instances et donc c'était un choix que
nous avons fait les organisations
professionnelles parce que sinon on
aurait pu aller sur une fermeture de nos
établissements et vous rendez compte
avec des avec 2 c de la période estivale
vous imaginez sur notre pays qui est
quand même plus de 50% côtier avec des
établissements fermés alors que c'est la
pleine saison
c'est pas possible sur paris c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué aussi parce que
nous n'avons pas de touristes mais il va
falloir mettre un gendarme devant chez
calcul établissements ça veut dire que
quelqu'un du personnel sera obligé de
contrôler avant de prise de consommation
le nez de flash et le passe à lithaire
de nos clients parce que la sanction est
lourde si toutefois il va y aura des
contrôles le problème c'est qu'il va y
avoir les contrôles et si l'offre si
vous n'avez pas flasher le le passé ni
terre de votre client vous allez vous
risquez une fermeture administrative et
vous risquez aussi une amende de 45000
euros dont une sans que des sanctions
sont très lourdes je pense que peut-être
le conseil d'état le conseil des sages
de réviser un petit peu ces sanctions
parce que aujourd'hui qu'elle est ça
peut arriver qu'un patron oublie de
prendre de flasher le qr code le perco
et surtout le fasse à lithaire de son
client j'espère qu'il y aura de la
tolérance mais je comprends aussi qu'il
fallait passer par là parce quand on
voit ce qui se passe
le maroc comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et qu'on voit qu'en france le
taux d'incidence augmente tous les jours
un peu plus
il fallait prendre les sanctions s'il
voulait pas se retrouver au mois d'août
au 15 août
confiné avec des établissements fermés
aujourd'hui l'économie ne peut pas se
permettre un recompte filmant et la
fermeture de nos établissements et nos
établissements sont déjà
est ce que concrètement des séquences
par exemple une baisse du nombre de
clients est ce que vous pensez que ça va
rebuter certaines personnes de devoir
venir devant les bars les restaurants
présentait se passe on peut imaginer que
ça va peut-être créer
une file d'attenté c'est sûr c'est que
des gens ne viendront pas du tout vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui ne viendront
pas les jeunes par exemple le passé
vacciner vous avez une jeunesse entre 18
et 26 ans ils ne sont pas vaccinés ils
vont organiser des fêtes même des
appartements où ils sont entassés au
centre sans gestes barrières sans
précaution aucune et donc cela le risque
va si bob haslé grandissant aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est une contrainte
supplémentaire
il fallait passer par là si aujourd'hui
la situation est compliquée le président
oui je penserai prendre les bonnes
décisions en avons discuté ensemble part
du président mal élu au conseil mais
c'était la solution qu'il fallait
adapter
il faut rappeler aussi que ce passeport
se passe sanitaire ce n'est pas égal
uniquement pour la vaccination puisqu'on
peut aussi se faire tester et justement
pour ce qui est du personnel des cafés
et restaurants comment est-ce que ça va
se passer selon vous ce qui ne sont pas
vaccinés vont devoir se faire tester
mais ce sera à quelle fréquence est ce
que vous avez des détails sur les
démarches à suivre
alors c'est justement un grave problème
parce que nous avons en plus en ce
moment beaucoup de com en a plein d
aider des jeunes ils sont venus dans
notre métier pour des saisonniers
le problème des saisonniers vous avez
beaucoup de ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés nous demandons à les faire
vacciner d'urgence ou alors des pc en
arrivant dans le rétablissement de façon
à ce qu'on prenne pas de risques parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous devons protéger nos
salariés et nous devons protéger nos
clients
donc là si l'afer est très compliqué
c'est pas facile
est-ce que donc selon vous ça va mettre
ça va mettre en péril votre les
restaurants et les bars c'est une ça va
voir une conséquence économique
on ne pourra pas surtout obligé alors
que les bars ont déjà subi la pandémie
de plein fouet avec la fermeture de
leurs portes durant des mois et des mois
tout à fait se retrouver avec un manque
de salaire et déjà nous avions des
problèmes pour recruter des saisonniers
avec c'est avec ce problème de
l'obligation de vaccins pour nous sa
peau pour nos saisonniers
on va se retrouver avec une pénurie
grandissante de deux salariés je suis
très inquiet pour la saison
parce que là elle a à peine commencé on
arrive à la semaine du 14 juillet
jusqu'au 15 septembre ça mais je suis
très inquiet on a encore peut-être du
mal d'eux on va avoir du mal je pense
que c'est financièrement savait pas
encore douloureux et on ne sait pas si
on les aide ne le décrit le dz n'est pas
sortie pour le mois d'août
on sait pas comment ça va se passer mais
beaucoup d'établissements sur paris
renfermé au mois d'août
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions marcelo benzema je rappelle
que vous êtes restaurateur merci à vous